hervé bonsoir soir je voyais vous
regardiez la la phrase de cette victime
qui dit les politiques c'est comme des
gangsters qui parle de honte
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que pouvait
leur répondre je comprends la souffrance
de ces personnes
mais il ne faut pas que cette
souffrance-là engendre l'injustice et
l'addition qui me concerne est une
décision que je considère comme
profondément injuste vous êtes allé plus
loin vous avez laissé entendre qu'au
fond c'était une décision politique et
non pas une décision de justice
parfaitement grâce à cette décision et
obtenu par 8 voix contre 7
le droit la justice n'ont pas participé
à cette décision là alors je rappelle il
y à des cours de justice république des
députés des sénateurs qui vient de la
droite et de la gauche une majorité
d'élus de droite
donc vous pensez que ce sont les élus de
droite qui vous ont condamné
l'arithmétique est là et c'est le sens
de sédition ce que je voudrais c'est que
l'on puisse aller au fond de ce qui
s'est passé de ses décisions
d'abord je constate que la cour ne me
fais aucun reproche concernant les
hémophiles
la cour ne me fais aucun reproche
concernant le dépistage que me reproche
nal elle me reproche de ne pas avoir
procédé au rappel les transfusés en 1985
le rappel des transfusés a eu lieu en
france à la fin de 1992 et au début de
1993 bernard kouchner qui l'a fait
parfaitement
est-ce que vous pensez que par exemple
ceux qui vous ont succédé au ministère
de la santé devrait être à leur tour mis
mis en justice est bien la question se
pose car si moi je suis condamnée pour
ne pas avoir fait le rappel des
transfusés en 1985 alors que je n'avais
pas les connaissances que l'on a acquise
ultérieurement
la question doit aussi se poser mais ce
n'est pas la même mais sur ce problème
précis est ce que vous regrettez de ne
pas l'avoir fait mais nous avons pris
une circulaire en octobre 1985 qui
prévoyait précisément des enquêtes de
transfusionnelle et je voudrais dire
qu'à l'époque personne n'a parlé du
rappel des transfusés et je voudrais
dire que lorsque nous avons pris nous
dise
en 1985 tout le monde a applaudi les
décisions que nous avons prises le 16
septembre 1985 j'ai même reçu une lettre
de félicitations des hémophiles 86-87 je
me souviens de ma baraque louant la
politique anti sida que nous avons
menées en 1985 et c'est beaucoup
d'années plus tard qu'il y à une
relecture une reconstruction d'histoire
et c'est là que l'on s'aperçoit que le
droit a été mis à mal et que ce procès
est un procès très dur et que cette
décision est une décision que je
qualifierais d'absurde
mais vous pensez que vous êtes quoi vous
payer pour tout le monde nous est le
bouc émissaire c'est à chacun de le
savoir vous ce soir vous pensez qu'en ce
qui me concerne c'est très sain moi je
suis très heureux que laurent fabius et
georgina dufoix été relaxé on a voulu
tuer politiquement laurent fabius
on n'y est pas arrivé moi je suis dans
la situation où je dois continuer de me
battre je vis une épreuve
je suis intimement convaincu qu'en 1985
j'ai fait dans le contexte médical et
scientifique de l'époque ce que je
devais faire je le dis en mon âme et
conscience mais monsieur hervé vous
comprenez bien les victimes parce que si
effectivement les politiques ne sont pas
coupables s'il n'y a pas de coupable
lors elles ont plus que leurs yeux pour
pleurer elles vont compter les morts et
les gens dire bah c'est la fatalité que
je souhaite c'est que l'on analyse
exactement ce qui s'est passé en 1985 en
france et dans l'ensemble des pays du
monde et que constatons nous nous
constatons que ce qui s'est passé en
france au cours de ces années c'est
également passé dans les autres pays
mais c'est sûr sauf pour le sang qui
venait dé prison sauf sauf pour les
décisions politiques qui ont quand même
relativement ardennes au nom précisément
quand vous prenez par exemple la
décision du dépistage en france
la france a été l'un des tout premiers
pays au monde à prendre cette décision
et en ce qui concerne le chauffage nous
sommes également extrêmement bien placé
alors il est vrai que nous avons eu à
faire en 81
1 84 85 à certaines pratiques
chirurgicales par exemple qui
utilisaient de manière très importante
la transfusion
c'est une particularité que l'on n'a pas
rencontré ailleurs monsieur hervé on va
pas refaire le procédé est ce que ce
soit vous avez des regrets vous dit
j'aurais peut-être dû agir autrement le
mon cabinet n'a peut-être pas aussi bien
fonctionné que ça j'aurais dû être plus
vigilant l'égard de certains des
collaborateurs
lorsque je regarde se passer lorsque je
regarde ce contexte dont 2 je vous ai
parlé
nous avons pris à l'époque les bonnes
décisions et personne personne ni
l'ordre des médecins ni l'académie de
médecine ni les associations
d'hémophiles non contestées l'édition
que nous avons prises au mois d'août
1985 j'ai fait une conférence de presse
pour expliquer aux autres nos décisions
le professeur montagnier professeur
rozenbaum était là tout le monde a
soutenu les décisions que nous avons
prises et au parlement que ce soit au
sénat que ce soit l'assemblée nationale
personne 84,85 n'a contesté mais
l'édition qui étaient les nôtres je je
je reprends ma question monsieur ray
dans ces cas là je vais requis les
victimes ont-elles se tourner est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est parce que vous
avez un physique plus austère que les
autres que vous êtes moins parisien que
les autres que que vous étiez plus
sympathiques comme on dit que vous êtes
condamné
je ne mets pas tous ceux ci au compte
des motivations
ce que je veux dire c'est que concernant
les victimes
et concernant le drame qui est le leur
tous les jours je vis avec ce drame mais
il ne faut pas que la souffrance
engendre une injustice qu'est lesquels l
avenir politique que vous dessinez
maintenant je crois profondément à
l'idéal qui est le mien j'ai vu comment
une certaine justice dans laquelle je ne
me reconnais pas pouvait fonctionner
l'accord du 6 e république la cour de
justice de la république
mais je n'oublie pas aussi que dans le
cas de cette cour il ya une instruction
qui a été fait par trois hauts
magistrats de la cour de cassation qui
appartiennent à l'élite judiciaire
française j'ai vu comment ces trois
hauts magistrats avait procédé à partir
de préjugés à partir de sélections sauf
que le procureur avait conclu à un
non-lieu l'humour mais se trouve que
c'est sur l'arrêt de renvoi que la cour
de justice a fonctionné
monsieur avez vous auriez préféré être
jugés par des jurés dans une cour
d'assises
lorsque je me suis présenté devant cette
cour
j'ai dit que je me soumettais bien
évidemment à cette cour
c'est une cour qui a été décidé selon la
constitution tout à fait normalement et
en tant que justiciable
je ne récuse pas cette cour mais il est
évident que en tant que citoyen en tant
que parlementaire je m'interroge sur
cette cour car je pense que justice et
politiques ne peuvent pas faire bon
ménage
on a aujourd'hui la preuve à aucun
moment vous n'avez pensé quitter vos
mandats maire de rennes députés mais
mandat de la population
lorsque j'ai été élu en 1995 et en 1997
j'ai été mis en examen pour complicité
d'empoisonnement situation difficile
ce ne sont pas huit personnes de droite
qui remettront en cause ses mandats la
mairie cette confiance là pardon de vous
poser la question mais qui est coupable
d'après vous alors c'est y qui s'invite
et collectives ce sont les médecins par
exemple je souhaite c'est que l'on
puisse analyser les choses
parlons de la science la science
n'évolue pas de manière unilatérale
elle va elle vient hélas et doute lassé
erreur le savoir qu'ils se constituent
ne se constitue pas du jour hommes
et lorsque l'on fera lorsque l'on fait
l'histoire de cette question on constate
que jamais au monde
il y a eu aussi peu de temps entre la
découverte du rétrovirus et d'autre part
la mise en application du dépistage
je souhaite que l'on prenne ceci en
considération tout comme je souhaite
bien évidemment que la solidarité
nationale
s'exprimer continue de s'exprimer au
bénéfice des victimes
merci monsieur reste